[Music]
it's weird it's harder for me much
harder for me to like write jokes
without
a crowd yeah like i like taking an idea
up there and kind of like letting their
energy dictate where we go with it i'm
almost like
i'm way worse at it i can be up there
and people are oftentimes like how do
you think of that in the moment and i'm
just like how does somebody think of
this
not right in the moment right right you
just sit around and think of clever
[ __ ] it just seems weird did you have
trouble with that
uh with that situation when you went to
sit and deliver the netflix stuff
because you don't you like don't have
that crowd there like when you when you
say the jokes for the netflix thing do
these guys all laugh
no we like we because they've already
heard it probably well yeah
yeah mark mark and i wrote it right
there's a couple other fa and robbie
slovak can give them and then akash will
help us as well so it's like
we all knew what was coming sometimes
alex
we usually would like you know basically
go through it once with alex just to
make sure there wasn't something too
racist
he was like a buffer for racism like and
he
literally usually if there was something
he laughed really hard at at the end
he'd be like oh yeah you gotta get rid
of that
like
uh but uh but yeah so like everybody
knows so
this is delayed satisfaction right it's
like we all are waiting
for it to post on youtube or post on
netflix or post on instagram and then
we're just
kind of seeing hoping people like it but
the thing is we're so close to the
content
by the time we release it we're like oh
none of this is funny right
like there's not a single funny joke in
the whole thing because we've watched it
and rewritten it and rewritten it and
rewritten it for [ __ ] months
so like having people i think that the
first day it came out like mark was so
[ __ ] terrified before
like the first project he gets to work
on is a netflix show
he's 23 years old and also the most
stylish
just thank you person i've ever met my
brother i know i roll up last night he's
got the rude shorts
the same shorts hasn't changed
still tucked i was talking all i ever
just closed that like friends sent me
like this is
what is this video game [ __ ] that you're
in what's going on with this what do i
do are you like tw twitch are you
talking about twitch yeah like oh out of
nowhere you're like i do video games bro
i do
you know like stephen a smith but for us
you know how people always say that when
you play video games find your find your
love find your passion and dive in
100 video games no no no i i don't do
that i've done every
heroine yeah that was from that was like
that
yes that one i did full board no
distractions mom
shut up i'm doing my heroine today shut
the [ __ ] up mom
nobody talks about that kind of
commitment oh it's a huge commitment
nobody sacrifices more than a drug
addict that's true they're about that
life
sacrificing god you give up everything
you love that's fact
that's what always makes me think it's
got to be worth it
i mean i got a best-selling book out of
it so for me totally worth it you know
it was yeah for me but if you don't
what's the spleen
yeah [ __ ] you could have it take it i
don't need it after i'm 18 anyways it
stops producing antibodies
is that what a spleen does yeah
producing so you're just out here in a
covered world with no
antibodies and no ability to produce
them no but i think
i think that herpes anti-virals kick in
for corona too
so yeah wait what is that that was a
joke no one laughed bro
i i i was actually like hold on yeah
yes book yes book number two yes book
number one
being picked up and made into a movie
yes youtube yes podcast yes twitch yes
like bro here's the problem like i'm
doing everything
yeah and now that is the heroine you
know what i'm saying that is
that is the drug and so it's like when
when you meet lana who deserves the
world because yeah she was the rocket
fuel lately to the rocket ship yeah and
she's like yo can we just like get a
lunch or something i'm like baby i'm
shooting
like i don't i can't do it wow you said
no to her for us
uh for you guys for you guys she would
allow it
you know what i'm saying because she you
want to know why why because she sees
y'all as like real
like because of the comedy thing
it's the same and the same she went to
she was like these guys aren't getting
into no trouble
[ __ ] dorks party with sam and tacos
oh my god they got side salads what a
bunch of queers
it was so funny it was so funny watching
jake with 14 watches on reach into a
[ __ ]
cheetos
i a little with empanadas from a local
bakery
yo we're the goats bro we've been doing
that it goes great
huh that food was great oh no my girl
could whip it down yeah yeah
yo who are these uh syrian migrants that
you brought into the studio
who are these guys so i was actually uh
that's the caravan bro that's the
caravan
is that the caravan did you bring them
in we went out on a yacht yesterday
both shooters they're both shooters yeah
there's no ones that one's like
video and the other one's like a shooter
like a real shooter oh he holds it down
he's like i know i'm just playing like
what is he shooting no they're both
camera guys so like so like one one
actually shoots for logan's
uh subscription club because we're
awesome we got a subscription club too
by the way one of my other
other other things i don't know any of
these let's talk about it after and then
um
the other one uh justin is gonna is
gonna start shooting with me because
it's just
just having the camera with you all the
time that's how you get like the the
real gold
cause we turned it on dude like imagine
if somebody had a camera last night for
your [ __ ] at the house last night with
logan and jake there we were just
shooting all that
got no views
he's like the paul brothers just ate
what they used to do [ __ ] for
they sit on couches and [ __ ] eat
salmon tacos the parties
who are the goats brothers ain't trying
to impress nobody i am good
y'all get snacks bro that's the
chocolate because i was so much happier
i
left i was like i could hear the
commentary yeah oh yeah
we wanted to talk about football we all
got to sit on the couch exactly
nah man you know what it is it's like
i'll be honest i just like
shooting the [ __ ] and talking and there
was a little part of me that's why i
wanted you guys to just come cause i was
like i just want all of us to hang out
and jake i want him to come to this fine
just hang out watch the game but once
like
20 people once the shorty started
showing up i was out
you know what it was it's just tougher
because
i didn't want it to become like a social
moment yeah yeah do you know what i mean
like yeah we shot a little video outside
that's fine but like
i just won't do this that's what i love
about a podcast it's like
it's not interrupted where we're trying
to like throw [ __ ] on the gram or
whatever like that like i just
i enjoy your company yeah so i just want
to pick your brain about [ __ ] you can
pick my brain about
just have some and i was kind of looking
forward to that a little bit and then
there's girls walking through the
[ __ ] living room with thongs on
it was so funny that was stuff it was
terrifying
what i'm supposed to do i literally told
my girls like you see these girls are
wearing thongs and then i realized like
i'm just admitting i'm looking at these
girls
snitching on yourself
you